okay we are back on the internet now
senator Sanders Chris our asks you what
is the future of independent parties yes
we had angus King here last week he's an
independent you're an independent but
there are precious few there are I am
longest-serving independent an American
congressional history and proud of that
and you are not too old to be President
I mean that I was speaking partly to you
with that little thank you know that we
got to get over that prejudice or else
you're dead before you start well I
think you know there is growing
frustration with the two-party system
and where more people want to look
outside of the system but using the word
independent is not good enough although
that says you know Democrat Republican
but what are you well I think we need to
do is see the growth of a progressive
independent movement in this country
where people are gonna focus on the
needs of working families and those
people who are really hurting
economically okay but we got to get over
that age thing yeah we didn't know your
pooh-poohing that but I'm telling you
know it's it you know I can't believe
senator Sanders and Governor Brown
aren't mentioned more it's always Martin
O'Malley the other that's why I know
it's it's it's a it's a terrible
prejudiced nation that they shouldn't be
afraid though to get in the arena to
just give it a run I mean why not you
know who kind of poisoned the well was
st. regan you know he would don't oh he
was old and he lost his marbles in
office so everybody's afraid that's
gonna public and phenomenons dole they
nominate McCain you could see the
Democrats but I doing brown or Sanders
right okay okay
this is Wilander are BAM H we're asks
what do you think the poor in this
country really need money
are you write him back yourself yeah
that's I don't know a question that I'm
gonna say this I'm what we need more
than anything is for people to look at
us and say thank you instead of [ __ ] you
yeah boy it comes down to you can ask me
what I need you can ask me what I want
there's forty five million of us there
is no easy answer the answer is to start
saying oh my god there's forty five
million of you how did we screw it up
this bad that's the answer so you know
what do we really need I don't know
leadership that actually pays attention
has actual solutions possibly a cultural
shift that leads to work being valued um
organ like a few I mean the number of
people who actually talk about the poor
I can name on less than one hand he's
one of them yeah I was gonna say we got
like two sitting up the table at least
that I know Warren senator Warren that's
another one a Paul Ryan has is was
centage but he's and you know all right
he took a hold he really so Paul Ryan
loses in 2012 and he takes it's huge
poverty tour in 2013 trying to change
his profile he's trying to get the party
moving in that direction I'm not saying
it's gonna be successful or not but he's
certainly talking about it well look but
Paul Ryan's got the opportunity grant
right and that's essentially life
coaching for poor people which is
fantastic if you're one of the minority
of poor people who needs life coaching
but sweetheart I'm busy at work and I
don't really yeah I don't have time to
go to a resume class ya know it all due
respect to Paul Ryan he is chairman of
the Budget Committee which made massive
cuts in Medicaid and in food stamps and
in program after program that low-income
people desperately need and I'll say
this too I have yet to see anybody on
either side of the aisle talk
about these issues or even not talk
about them where I thought they were
being legitimately mean-spirited its
people who really have just kind of it
yeah they just Frazee way of helping
clueless but this is the same problem
like oral writes about it and downtown
Paris London right it's the same thing
where we just go oh well you know if
only poor people would stop doing x and
y and z and if we can somehow socially
engineer that to happen then poverty
goes away well let me tell you
somebody's always gonna have to scrub
the toilets around here it's never gonna
end
we're always gonna need a service
industry how do we make those people's
lives tolerable what do you do is have a
minimum wage which is a living wage
right I just can't believe the minimum
wage didn't become a big issue this year
I mean it's just kept fading you had a
bola and Isis creep up as the big issues
Democrats had some momentum on the
minimum wages right people got to take
that one time we should have all stopped
right Patchen Ebola look Mexican Isis in
with the bowl you know uh Lisa Kudrow
what was the hardest part about bringing
back to come back no I love that
question yeah well I didn't ask it Mikey
asks it yeah
Oh Mikey I know Mikey yeah I'd like to
think I do but um the hardest part was
oh well the scariest part was that there
the fans of the show are pretty devoted
so you just really didn't want to let
them down
right that was tough I think we did a
good job but you'll see looking at you
yeah like when do they start Sunday Oh
shorty right oh this Sunday night yeah
you like it
what a coincidence at your on deck
before your show goes on the air right
now wow that is that is the
spookie I didn't have that's weird
okay uh could refusing to compromise
with Republicans actually enhance
President Obama's legacy hmm I don't
know what that means that's the big
question about immigration right does he
do executive action or not yeah I mean I
think ultimately his legacy will be
defined by what are the policies he put
in place and what were the effects of
those policies and as long as
Republicans control Congress which they
will for the remainder of the time that
he is president they have control in
some way over what policies do or don't
get an actin so I think if he has other
things he wants to add to the list of
policies that are part of his legacy
he's for whether you think that's a good
thing or not he's got to work with these
Republicans in Congress
it doesn't ride against week that they
were playing this little game of chicken
after the election where he was saying
you know I want to pass something on
immigration and I hope you want to help
me in the Congress because if you don't
if you don't do it I'm gonna do
executive action and then John Boehner
was like we'll have you do executive
action
somebody could get impeached I'm
wondering to what extent it's possible
instead of these kind of big
comprehensive bills if there are things
like smaller pieces of legislation that
are able to get through both chambers
and get to the President's desk but also
bear in mind just because Republicans
took the Senate they don't have 60 votes
in the Senate so now all those people
that hated the filibuster a week ago are
now gonna love the filibuster and all
the people that love the filibuster week
ago are about to hate it so we're about
to go through that whole fund transition
so we may ultimately not see a whole lot
happen out of Washington the next few
years if he stops cooperating do we get
a search in general surgeongeneral would
be nice Attorney General would be nice
any kind of general would be in general
okay Lisa we'll give you the last
question hunter D on the TV show scandal
you played a congresswoman and made a
powerful speech on sexes
uh-huh yeah that's right what is your
favorite color
no yeah do you feel that their
Republican war on women is still an
important issue to voters
there's the Republican war on women
that's what it says do you feel that the
Republican war on women is still an
important issue to voters there's a
Republican right yeah which part of
being a woman well you know I think he's
referring back to now this is something
the Republicans did improve upon I must
say back in 2010 they were the
legitimate rape people
they were the what they could not stop
talking about ladies private parts yeah
and this time they got the memo I guess
from Karl Rove who said you know what
just ixnay on talking about women's and
abortion you know we'd stop with you
know were the Republicans we want to
[ __ ] the living all right I gotta go
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen